more than 15,000 nursing homes
nationwide are trying to stop the corona
virus from sweeping through the nation's
most vulnerable population Connecticut
reportedly plans coronavirus only
nursing homes in western Massachusetts
11 veterans who lived at the soldiers
home in Holyoke died including five who
had tested positive another 11 residents
and five staff members also have
coronavirus Meg Oliver shows the
difficult situation for families with
loved ones in these facilities when I
would visit with my kids it was really
the highlight of her day
Alex handy suddenly lost her 86 year old
mother Lana
Irwin a week ago the great-grandmother
died from kovat 19 along with eight
others from this New Jersey nursing home
there was no time to say goodbye how
hard was that not to be able to say
goodbye to your mom the fact that she
passed away I can accept that but the
fact that I didn't get to say goodbye is
still what's eating me up inside across
the country kovat 19 has created a
crisis at nursing home facilities Sunday
more than 100 residents and staff tested
positive at this Tennessee
Rehabilitation Center outside Baltimore
a staggering 77 seniors tested positive
here what we our killing fields
nationwide long-term facilities house
three times the number of patients
hospitals do dr. Wasserman says we need
to transform more buildings into skilled
nursing facilities for seniors with
kovat 19 if we push older adults out of
hospitals and I see use into nursing
homes that will be overwhelmed in three
to four weeks the problem will be ten
times greater it's a dire prediction
families are worried sick about Kathy
Kahn CX has been Edward is recovering
from the virus in the hospital he was in
a nursing home after suffering a brain
injury and needs a
round-the-clock care I'm just really
gonna have to bring him home because I
can't trust anybody you've been married
40 years have you ever gone this long
without seeing him never I just can't
imagine what's happening to him and how
he's being treated and whether people
are doing the right thing I'm sure you
want to be there be by her side I do
absolutely for CBS this morning Meg
Oliver Montclair New Jersey and that's a
hardest not being able to be there when
you know you're needed most by a loved
one